george king four
nine two nora
[Music]
morgan where you go to this fancy car
[Music]
there's a beautiful car though are you
driving this thing so fast
oh trying to get back home
that's nice are you take it out for me
please
that's fine
hold on i'll get there
this is your vehicle are you mr robinson
gary dean
are you from baton rouge
[Music]
you say you don't have your driver's
license
can you have a driver license yes
now i gotta run you
no surprises
your driver's license is gonna be good
yeah i work i work right here at amazon
right here man you and everybody what's
up amazon and fedex tonight
you still live on mccarran street
1060.
all right mr robinson
roach 10 over everything else is good
you were doing 64. you're doing that
it could have been twice as bad
10 over
24th day of january tournaments downtown
or you do this website thing or over the
phone
[Music]
200 louis downtown
right go to courthouse yeah
or you can take care of my
mail
well this is not the new one the new one
still smells like it's new you know what
i'm talking about yeah yeah but uh they
built that other place for the tickets
100 uh louis yeah
that's the muni court now
i gave you only half price
i only gave you a half price
please sir take care of this thing
drive careful get home
you also sir
thank you